c'est un fait deux cent mille
téléspectateurs au makhzen est peut-être
que l'émission elle doit continuer ça
c'est un autre débat mais regarde je
vais prendre l'exemple avec vous quand
vous partez en laponie camp nou parts à
las vegas quand vous partez à votre
mission brouillé avec insert ont la peau
des accords mais quand vous parlez vous
parlez de personnalités vous avez pris
des gens ici qui ont tous fait quelque
chose dans leur vie va plus ou moins et
qui ont des personnalités aussi des gens
c'est bien sûr mais quand vous partez en
déplacement délocalisations il s'en fout
le bordel comme ça mais alors on n'a pas
20 ans bien sûr on n'a pas 20 ans ils
ont pas 20 ans mais ce n'est pas même
pas fait c'est quand même des enfants
quand même des enfants gâtés et qu'est
ce qui se serait passé s'il y avait eu
un truc comme ça avec quelqu'un de
shimano ça aurait été un bain questions
dans la fenêtre
voilà mais non répond la parcelle et on
est parfois je dis la vérité moi voilà
et jo j'ai tort moi il peut m'arriver
voilà si quelqu'un mais avec un manque
d'impact qu'un langage je me suis jamais
oubliés avec un mandat dans un
restaurant moi je me rappelle je me
rappelle de rien un truc je vous dire je
veux raconter une histoire
un jour je suis dans un restaurant voilà
dans paris et il ya un mec qui avec sa
meuf et j'entends chez que des copains
et il dit à sa mère arrête de regarder
le juif
aïe aïe aïe bon bah voilà un quart
d'heure après voilà on sait ça ça a
chauffé dont restaurant le restaurant
elle a fait sortir mais voilà c'est a
pas fait une émeute n'a pas fait un truc
je suis allé boire je ne pouvais pas
parler comme ça etc
mais il peut m'arriver mais aussi de
péter un câble mais là en l'occurrence
quand on me demande des photos quand
vous tous vous demandent des photos de
ça c'est le métier s'est voilé ça se
voulait pas faire de photos si vous
voulez manger tranquillement résideront
ne fait pas ce métier fait autre chose
voilà
et je vous dis et le public c'est ce qui
vous fait vivre c'est ce qui vous est ce
qu'ils vont mal on ten seafrigo regarde
pas le moi je vous le dis souvent en
télé et vous voyez je le fais à chaque
fois j'ai il m'arrive très souvent eu
voilà d'insultés de mal parler de gens
puissants de patron de télé de patrons
peu de voix là mais il ya un seul et
nous on a un seul et unique patron ici
c'est vous c'est pay je dis c'est pas
démago ce que je veux dire c'est juste
c'est vrai au demain vous le dis si on
marche plus et si on fait des audiences
de merde et je vous le dis vous pouvez
être hyper copain avec le patron allait
boire des verres tous les jours avec lui
ça méritait pas ira boire des verres
avec vous mais c'est tout mais le seul
et unique patron en télévision c'est le
public